[Music]
today we are making fried chicken I'm
not just any fried chicken a very very
special concoction of a fried chicken
recipe that I have decided to try over
the course of like the past year the
question is have you ever wondered what
Taiwanese popcorn chicken would taste
like on the bone Tom wayes hop corn
chicken is a live chicken nugget it's
usually served at Taiwanese cafes and
restaurants if you go to a boba store
more than likely they're gonna have
popcorn chicken there as a snack but
it's really really delicious it
incorporates soy sauce ginger and
Chinese five-spice in its marinade and
it creates a very very distinct flavor
profile and that flavor profile I am
absolutely in love with it's the same
flavor that they use for the really
really popular Taiwanese dish pork chop
over rice I grew fun with my manner is
really really bad but uh that's the only
men are you're gonna get out of me today
but yeah so I was asking these questions
like how come they can't just make that
flavor profile with a whole chicken with
you know chicken on the bone and the sad
truth about the eating experience these
days is that everyone's going for
simplicity and convenience and overall
cleanliness chicken for example has been
turned into fillets chicken strips
chicken nuggets chicken sandwiches and I
feel that eating chicken on the bone
just good old-fashioned fried chicken is
starting to fall to the wayside nothing
replaces fried chicken on the bone for
me so anyways I decided to experiment
and I'd come up with a pretty pretty
delicious recipe for five-spice fried
chicken
[Music]
all right so first up we have our
ingredient spread obviously we're gonna
have the chicken here I'm using a picnic
pack and has a combination of chicken
thighs and chicken drumsticks I like my
dark meat not a really big fan of white
meat when it's being fried it tends to
dry out but if I was being healthy I
would use white meat and if I was being
healthy I probably wouldn't even be
eating fried chicken to begin with
anyways dark meat
roughly 4.5 pounds of dark meat for the
spices we have then you cross-reference
with my ingredients book one teaspoon of
paprika 1 teaspoon of cayenne pepper 2
teaspoons of Chinese five-spice 2
teaspoons of white pepper one teaspoon
of black pepper and 1 teaspoon of salt
now the Chinese five-spice as you can
tell by the name it has roughly 5 spices
in it but some people might even refer
to it as a cinnamon spice mix penning on
who where you get your five-spice from
but whatever it is five-spice has a very
distinct flavor and that flavor does
come from the star and nice kind of a
cinnamon a flavor five-spice is the key
ingredient here that is gonna give our
fried chicken that distinct Taiwanese
popcorn chicken flavor alright moving on
to the wet ingredients we got 2
tablespoons of soy sauce 2 tablespoons
of oyster sauce now Oster sauce is a
condiment from Cantonese cuisine where I
think they just turn Easter's into sauce
doesn't sound delicious but it's
fantastic condiment you should
definitely give it a try and three
tablespoons of Chinese rice cooking wine
and lastly our fresh ingredients now
when I first experiment with this recipe
I was using onion powder garlic powder
ginger powder all these things that I
find that
to create that Asian flavor you
definitely need to use a mixture of
fresh ingredients so and so using the
powdered forms I've opted to use fresh
ingredients here we have roughly three
tablespoons of minced garlic we'll need
three tablespoons of minced ginger and
three tablespoons of green onions
actually this might be more than three
tablespoons it's three stalks of green
onions diced there's a lot of
ingredients involved but cooking process
wines we're just in throw everything
together in a big bag and super super
easy let's get started we are gonna take
a jumbo size plastic bag so it goes
chicken next I like to pour in the wet
stuff just so there's something sticky
there's spices and the fresh ingredients
can cling on to next the fresh
ingredients green onions ginger and
lastly our plate of spices and just dump
all of that in there
and once we have that done we're gonna
go zip it up lock it and massage and I
like to turn it upside down right side
up sideways I just want to get all the
fluid and spices and fresh ingredients
make sure every piece of chicken is
covered and our beater beautiful flavors
and once you've got it done massage
we're gonna place them into the fridge
and we're gonna wait one hour if you
have the time two hours is great every
house is great for hours great overnight
probably the most ideal just to get like
that full essence of the flavor but
today since we're making this video I
only have one hour spare next while
we're waiting for the chicken to
marinate we are going to set up our
dredging station for frying station 1 2
whole eggs whisked station 2 flour 2
whole cups of flour and then the past
I've also tried adding spices to the
flour mix just to you know add more
flavor but I think
got over border the flavor from before
so we're gonna keep it simple two whole
eggs and flour all right and move it
over to our skillet we are going to fill
up this skillet up to the halfway mark
turn on the stove don't wait for the oil
to heat up I keep it really really
simple with checking the temperature of
the oil I don't have a fancy thermometer
not that thermometers are extremely
fancy I just don't have a thermometer so
if you also don't have a fancy
thermometer for checking the temperature
of your oil when you're frying I like to
take a trusty old chopstick stick it
straight down into the oil and hold it
there for a few seconds and then within
a few seconds if it starts to sizzle the
tip of your chopstick and basically
frying your chopstick then that's when
you know you're that the oil is hot
enough to start tossing in some fried
chicken before we start I also want to
mention that when you fry your chicken
you also want to have your bag of
chicken pulled out from the fridge maybe
half an hour just so that it's not cold
when you're frying it so what we want to
do is have the chicken closer to room
temp so that it cooks evenly so the
outside doesn't burn and the Excite is
is raw a lot your fried chicken and into
the egg wash it goes and it's okay if
the vegetables the herbs start falling
off little bits gonna happen but trust
the marinating process the flavor is
there all that flour will become the
eventual brunch that we all look forward
to when eating fried chicken so make
sure you get that flour pressed into the
chicken as much as you can gently place
the chicken into the batch of oil and
let the frying commence
braised chicken part there's gonna be a
different amount of cooking time
involved for drumsticks 15 minutes of
frying time and then for chicken thighs
I like to go for a whole 20 minutes as
you cook you want to flip the chicken
pieces every two minutes and honestly
just sit back enjoy staring out the vat
of oil frying your chicken all right so
now that we have all our fried chicken
finished smells amazing
looks amazing before you decide to bite
into your wonderful fried chicken make
sure to let it rest for 10 to 15 minutes
because when it comes to frying why
fried chicken is so juicy is the fact
that the crust traps the moisture inside
it traps the heat it traps
everything that's delicious about this
fried chicken inside that crust and so
the temperature is also very very hot
and doesn't cool down as fast as other
types of cooking methods in that time I
like to create my own hot sauce there's
a lot of wonderful hot sauces out there
Louisiana Tabasco whatever you like to
use what I like to do you're at home
this take some classic sriracha in the
theme of the Chinese Taiwanese
asian-inspired thing that we've got
going on here with this dish one part
sriracha and one part vinegar and what
that does is it liquefies the sriracha
closer to Tabasco or your traditional
American hot sauce but has a unique
Asian flavor profile so biting into this
project and it really does taste like
that comedy's popcorn chicken if it had
more chicken flavor so yes if you are a
fan of fried chicken and you want to try
a different flavor profile other than
your typical buttermilk fried chicken
I implore you to try five-spice fried
chicken and let me know what you think
type in the comments down below tell me
it sucks tell me it's great tell me what
I should make next and see you next time
thanks for watching
[Music]